aujourd'hui on va parler d'un vin le
jurançon rien à voir avec le jura c'est
dans le béarn aux portes de pau le
jurançon qui s'apprécie au repas comme à
l'apéro laurence de chair et frédéric
fort entre le soleil et la terre des
pyrénées il est des cépages qu'on ne
trouve qu'ici dans le béarn la vigne du
jurançon a beaucoup poussé depuis le
printemps sur les coteaux et pour être
certain de récolter les deux kilos de
raisin le premier chaque pied il faut
éclaircir l'invitation déborde et
recommencent à retomber faudra couper et
maintenant vient le temps où on enlève
la visitation les entrepeneurs la
végétation superflu qui n'a rien à faire
sur un pied de vigne et qui surtout
comme fine levens jeunes certaine
humidité humidité dangereuse pour pour
avoir un bon raisin cern
au mois de novembre quand ce raisin sera
récoltée quoi car ici les vendanges se
font toujours tardivement
arrière saison saison des avant goûts
c'est la banque ou des vendanges que
nous offrent actuellement avec deux
semaines pour obtenir en raison presque
confie
dans le chai la cuvée de l'an passé
prend son temps toute l'année il faut
remuer les dépôts de levure ces résidus
de la fermentation je suis en train de
bâtonnets les verne les 2004 de la
dernière de la dernière récolte quoi je
remets les lits en suspension pour que
le vincent nourrissent pour que le vern
a stabilisé ses arômes et capte un peu
plus de volume un peu plus de deux
longueurs dans sa future dégustation les
mille hectares du vignoble permettent la
commercialisation de 7 millions de
bouteilles le jurançon aujourd'hui une
sur cinq par à l'étranger en quinze 153
le futur roi henri iv est baptisé au
jurançon
même si le vin tire sa noblesse de cette
époque il n'a pas toujours eu sa
réputation d'aujourd'hui il ya trente
ans en fait jonction était un vin de
comptoir c'est un vin qui était
consommée en fait ici au sud de l'adour
et c'est vrai qu'en fait grâce à des
beaucoup d'investissements tant au
niveau de la vigne qu'au niveau des
chais de vinification on a énormément
amélioré la qualité les jurançon d'où
sont devenus beaucoup plus riches
beaucoup plus puissant et le jurançon
sec sont plus fins et plus élégant sec
ou plus souvent brûlés le jurançon est
toujours appelé le vin des rois 350
viticulteurs perpétue aujourd'hui ce
savoir faire ancestral
à consommer malgré tout avec modération